I'm thinking about all the different
people you've collaborated with because
you mentioned Ray Charles but what what
what's amazing to me is that uh you have
I think a very enviable career you
you've had massive commercial success
and you're respected and you're a nice
grounded person and you can so like that
you know of
let me find out word gets
word gets out yeah yeah yeah I guess I
talk to Uber drivers and they tell me um
but like you've collaborated with Keith
Richards yeah what's that like
again just like a nice human you know a
musician yeah yeah sometimes you do
these collaborations and the song's
already been recorded and the person's
not even there and you go in and you add
your vocals and I've done a couple of
those with Keith but I've actually been
in a room playing music with him a few
times and it's incredible I would yeah
that would be sort of Otherworldly yeah
um
you know I just uh in the few times that
I've had little contacts with him oh
yeah very you know like he didn't know
who I was or anything
um but I'm sure that's not true no no
this was years ago before I you weren't
wearing a new little t-shirt I had it on
even when I was before I had a TV show I
had it on
um but uh it feels to me like it would
be a great exercise to one
one might not immediately link Nora
Jones and Keith Richards but you can get
together and musically you guys can yeah
find find the groove or find what it is
I mean we both love Hank Williams right
so I it's not a problem it's it's it's a
language and it's like that that's
what's so fun about this podcast is it's
like a never-ending list of people to
just play with and play music with but
it's like really just like playing in a
playground you know it's like that it's
so fun and do you have like your bucket
list of these are the people I've got to
have on your on your podcast that you
want to mess around with it's just never
ending it's yeah it's a bazillion people
it's like of course you know my Idols or
or a Young musician who I admire or
someone that nobody knows about that I
just like or you know whoever I mean
that's so fantastic yeah and I think
that's what this medium this podcast
thing
what I'm I I mean every time we come
into the studio I I'm delighted that
this form exists me too it's it's like
intimate yeah and fun and it's it's I'm
never you know gonna get invited to
dinner with you probably so it's fun to
just have this time together to talk and
I know you've asked a lot I'm still not
ready
find that very hard to believe yeah yeah
I just need to hear a little more of
your stuff but you know what I mean like
there's a lot of people you might not
cross paths with in an intimate way well
that's so that's a way to really connect
yeah that's what I was I was uh on my
way to work today and I called
the the guy who's a good friend and he
booked music on our show all through the
90s 2000's Jim Pitt oh yeah I remember
him yeah and you know great person who
uh helped put the really put the musical
stamp on on my show which was so
important to us and um I called him up
and I just was as excited and I said hey
I'm going to be I just want you to know
I'm going to be talking to uh Nora in
like half an hour and he was like oh my
God and we were chatting about how nice
it is and I said to him
all these years Nora's been coming on
my show and Performing and of course we
chat but I never got to sit down with
you and talk to you yeah because people
don't realize show business is you know
you do your your set your sound check
your rehearsal I come down I say hi then
I've got to go and do my stuff then you
perform I thank you and then you move on
I move on yeah it's brief yeah and this
is this is what I love yeah you know
it's so much it's so like warm it gives
me the warm fuzzies you know because I
didn't know that uh country music was so
important to you yeah and I didn't grow
up in Texas yeah it was in the water
yeah you know and my mom's from Oklahoma
so this is it's a familial thing on that
side of my family do you have a favorite
Hank Williams song
um I mean so lonesome Micah cries just
about one of the best songs ever ever
sung yeah yeah yeah and sad I love that
Ken Burns documentary on uh country
music oh yeah yeah and you know he's
taking you through everybody and then he
gets to the there's the chapter episode
about Hank Williams and it's entitled
Shakespeare of the South oh
like yeah that's right that's right yeah
I mean I love that music
um but also you get to like work with
outcasts Foo Fighters yeah so it's run
the gamut I've been super lucky yeah has
anyone ever asked you like can I do a
duet with you and it was someone you do
not want to do that with you mean do I
say yes to everything
I just meant in person you know I meant
like the awkwardness in person yeah like
you're talking to someone who like let's
do this yeah well actually I'm ready to
do a duet with you yeah
it never happened like that ever but
yeah I mean I've turned a few down I
guess I've got my ukulele I have my
bassoon
on we could do it right now I would do
that probably it was just like really
easy but um I I don't know I I've turned
a few things down I've turned a few
things down where I really liked the
person and I just didn't have time you
know stuff just happens but doing this
podcast it's like I have to actually ask
people now and that's kind of
nerve-wracking first to ask people to
come be on my my show now right and and
being in that position of asking and
maybe getting rejected that's been like
the most kind of like oh I don't know
what I'm doing you know you know what's
funny uh I'll just just because I've
been doing this for so long uh I used to
take it personally yeah if someone
couldn't come on the show or said no to
the show I took it as them saying Conan
O'Brien uh thank you no yeah and jerk
that guy yeah and then later on it took
me years because my my publicist used to
say no don't take it personally they're
in town yeah and then I realized because
I'd been on the other side of it it
where I'm someplace and they'll say like
hey there are these five people that or
these five shows that are saying can you
come do something and you think I'm only
here for a day I can do one or I don't
really want to do that this time or I
can't do it yeah and you realize that
it's not personal at all I mean
sometimes it is sometimes celebrities
say I despise that guy and I don't
realize why that has to get back to me
from them personally yeah yeah George
Clooney calls and says no no no no you
are not my cup of tea you're way too
silly uh
um if only that were joke uh oh come on
oh come on not Clooney I'm just no no no
he loves me we'll connect eventually uh
but no no let's not put that out there
or do we oh what's that I want George
Clooney yeah really can you be better
can you change yourself
go get him tiger try I'm gonna try and
up my game yeah thank you get all of
Oceans 11 in here
at the same time yeah please I think I
could get two of them Carl Reiner no no
no you can't get him anymore I could
have I could have but uh we'd need some
voodoo magic to get him now nice one
Gorly by the way yeah I picked the one
guy who's not alive yeah no I'm talking
about waiter number three oh okay oh
he's good though yeah
um what is your
I thought you just went right back into
a question that's what I have to do I'm
a pro
Nora gets it because she's a pro I'm
sorry I'm sorry right you run a podcast
you know how to just snap back I love
when you get Sona going it's my favorite
thing when I get her angry no when you
get her laughing like I want to get her
laughing when she gets going it's my
favorite thing too actually well it must
feel so good to laugh like that it does
it's rare to laugh like that
and then also just working for someone
for for Conan O'Brien has been of course
well I think the thing that comes uh
that that is real is uh how much
happens between Sona and I uh
and laughing that isn't recorded yeah
because I will call you and say there's
something really important I need you to
do for me and then it's something that's
completely made up yeah yeah and um
he'll go on riffs on the phone with me
just because I'm laughing and I think
it's a because it's a drug it is good to
have her around it is he's such a great
laugh oh thank you thank you probably
less so no Worley isn't really a laugh
girlie is funny as hell I know yeah
I remember when I first started
listening to your podcast he was just
kind of quieter yeah well he's a quiet
and then he started he's really come out
yeah oh yeah and now guess what now
we're trying to get him back again
it's like it's one it's a Jack In The
Box that I'm trying to jam yeah get back
into the box can't do it
really well no no it's it's I got very
lucky because this all came together I
mean Sono I knew was going to be part of
it and then uh they brought this girly
guy in yeah and I said absolutely not
and they said no one else will do it and
then that's true that's true because I
was being blackmailed oh my God it's a
beautiful thing